-Thanks to newly developed
technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have the ability
to record the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head
and you might be surprised
to know that,
like everyone's inner voice,
Donald Trump's is filled
with paralyzing fear
and self-doubt.
So, here it is,
the tiny voice in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
-Hey, Donald, it's the tin
voice in the back of your head
and it's time once again
for your least favorite thin
about the job,
waiting for foreign people
to stop talking
so you can eat your dinner
And you have to pretend
to listen and give a little nod.
Oh, good point.
I didn't understand
a word you said,
but I want to eat
these dumplings.
I'm going to look at them,
and I'm gonna steal a little
peek at my dumplings and..
there they are.
Okay, one, two, three.
That's good.
I'll eat those, and then Melania
will give me hers.
That's six, seven, eight.
So that's eight dumplings,
and maybe Shinzo's wife
will give me one or two.
That's 15, 16 dumplings.
That's a lot of dumplings.
This will be worth it,
but you have to stop talking
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]